l'europe n'est pas une option mais un
impératif
c'est vrai bien sûr en matière
économique c'est vrai bien sûr en
matière sociale c'est vrai aussi en
matière de protection et de protection
de nos frontières comme de protection
contre le terrorisme le terrorisme est
un fléau
un fléau qui depuis l'an 2000 a causé la
mort de 753 européen et de 375 français
c'est donc un mal qu'il faut combattre
avec énergie par tous moyens et l'europe
peut nous apporter cette aide c'est vrai
avec le passage gern aymeric horde c'est
à dire le registre des allers-retours
aérien dans toute l'europe qui donne de
nombreux renseignements sur les
habitudes sur les trajets sur le mode de
paiement sur les bagages c'est un
instrument indispensable qui permet de
suive est tracé et connaître les trajets
des citoyens européens et bien sûr ceux
qui sont à risque
donc cela nous aide à mieux appréhender
le danger potentiel c'est vrai aussi
avec le parquet européen qui doit se
doter de moyens complémentaires pour
être plus efficace dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme et c'est vrai aussi d'un
certain nombre d'initiatives comme les
agences europol comme les agences
eurojust qui ont bien sûr le mérite
d'exister déjà mais qui aujourd'hui ne
répondent pas suffisamment à ce nouveau
défi qui est un défi de civilisation
pour l'europe il y à face à nous des
terroristes qui veulent contester notre
liberté qui veulent contester notre mode
de vie tout simplement qu'ils veulent
contester notre civilisation et l'europe
doit se doter de nouveaux moyens pour
pouvoir répondre à ces nouveaux défis